right so what would I do if I could
redesign the world well I worked for a
long time at CERN and the journalists
once described us as there are people
who change their minds in the face of
evidence and I thought that's what you
should normally do but then I realized
that most people don't so if I could
read this on the world I would go full
out for anything that is evidence-based
and unfortunately that means to a large
extent fighting the historic please
things that have in the past been able
to satisfy our needs for understanding
the place that we're living in there but
are no longer justified now and I'm
talking about religion I'm adding
religion which is not evidence-based is
what's holding us back in getting to
evidence-based decision area so that is
also what I think the large part of this
forum is about how to move away from
sort of random decisions or emotional
decisions and trying to figure out what
works what doesn't work and use the
things that work so it's it's a very
positive approach I think and it's all
based on what you see it what the
results are where you can go with this
results it does not mean that we
shouldn't decide what we like or what we
want but the means to get there should
at least be based on evidence that's not
likely go to evidence place this is not